Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis avec Pacia ! Salut Pacia.
-Salut les gens ! Salut Fabien.
Pacia est un être spécial, c'est une magicieuse, c'est quoi une magicieuse ?
-C'est une magicienne malicieuse, donc c'est comme une magicienne mais en pire.
J'ai invité Pacia à la maison pour qu'elle vous fasse de la magie.
C'est tellement rare une femme magicienne, et c'est encore plus rare une femme magicieuse, et puis Pacia m'a dit
"mais moi je préférerai que tu me mentalises".
Parce que tu ne connais pas bien ça.
-Je découvre, et j'aime bien mais du coup étonne moi.
:D
-La pression !
T'as vu un peu le challenge !
Tu connais un peu le principe des nombre astrologiques ou pas ?
-Non, pas du tout.
En fait, c'est un peu comme la numérologie. Tu vas penser à une date dans ta tête.
Evidemment, pas ta date de naissance parce qu'on pourrait penser que je la connais ou que je l'ai cherché sur Facebook.
Donc tu penses à une date qui t'importes, soit la naissance de quelqu'un que tu aimes bien.
Tu as une date en tête ?
-Oui.
Formidable. Tu vas calculer le nombre astrologique dans ta tête. Je te laisse prendre tout le temps qu'il te faut.
Tu fais 2 fois le jour de naissance, plus le mois de naissance.
Tu es capable de le faire ? Prends ton temps. Tu me dis quand tu as fini, sans me dire le résultat évidemment.
-C'est bon.
Tu veux le recalculer ? Une dernière fois au cas où, pour voir si tu ne t'es pas trompée ?
Je vais déjà te demander de penser au mois qui correspond à la date, à laquelle tu penses.
Focalise-toi sur la deuxième lettre de ce mois, en général ce sont des voyelles.
-D'accord, c'est bon.
tu l'as dans ta tête?
Ok. Alors maintenant regarde moi dans les yeux.
Ca peut donc être:
Tu es très impassive. C'est donc très dur de te lire.
Vous avez vu ce petit signe de satisfaction.
Ahahahaha !
Ah oui c'est terrible ! C'est très très compliqué de te lire !
On va plutôt parler des chiffres !
[rires]
Je vais essayer de déterminer si le jour auquel tu penses, est un nombre pair ou impair.
Donc pense au jour auquel tu penses.
Et... je vais juste... faire
Pair ?
Impair ?
J'arrive rien à lire ! Donc maintenant tu diras "stop" dans ta tête quand je dis "pair" ou "impair".
La base est simple ?
-Ça va.
Pair ?
Impair ?
Ok, impair, c'est correct ?
-Oui c'est correct.
Ok ! Je vais y arriver !
[rires]
Je vais y arriver. D'accord... euh
Alors pour l'instant j'hésite entre deux. J'hésite entre 21 et...
23 !
Je dirai sur le 23 janvier, et ton nombre astrologique est le 47 !
-Oui !
Pourquoi le 23 janvier ?
-Parce que c'est la date de naissance de ma fille.
Ah d'accord ! Je ne pouvais pas le savoir. Ne dites pas ça... [rires]
Je les entends déjà derrière...
Tu ne mets pas d'infos sur Facebook ?
-Non, je n'affiche pas ma vie privée sur Facebook.
Ok, ouf ! Parce que là ils vont dire que c'était possible de voir tes infos sur Facebook.
Ecoute, ça fait très longtemps que je n'avais pas joué avec les nombres astrologiques donc je suis ravi d'avoir fait ça avec toi.
-Ça m'a vraiment bluffé !
Oui vraiment !
Cool !
Dimanche vous aurez une explication de tour qui sera sur l'influence de chiffres donc pas sur la lecture de chiffres, mais sur l'influence
et ça, ce sera votre petit bonus à vous !
C'était un plaisir d'avoir fait ça avec toi ! Une des rares femmes magicienne en France et la seule femme magicieuse
-Dans l'univers !
Dans l'univers.
-Oui, je suis la seule, l'unique.
Ouais, pas mal quand même !
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, avec Pacia et moi-même.
Si cette petite idée vous a plu vous pouvez nous le faire savoir en nous laissant un... pouce en l'air !
-Si vous avez aimé sa prestation vous faites un pouce en l'air, et si vous avez aimé la mienne, mettez un petit cœur.
Ah oui ! Alors sur Youtube on ne met que des pouces en fait.
-Mince ! Je ne connais pas...
Mais tu as raison, dans ce cas je partagerai la vidéo sur Facebook et nous y ferons un battle.
-Ouais !
Donc si vous étiez pour Pacia vous mettez un cœur, et si vous étiez pour moi vous mettez un pouce en l'air.
Et si vous étiez pour les deux...
-Alors dans ce cas, un grand sourire, un gros smiley !
Vous pouvez également commenter cette vidéo, j'y réponds des fois en retard mais j'y réponds toujours.
Vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaîne, parce que le MentalVlog c'est une vidéo par jour, pendant un an,
donc rendez-vous demain à 11H.
Ciao !